[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but this guy's a winner he's uh
christian polisik the chelsea uh
midfielder
usa soccer had the big win against
mexico he scored
in that win against mexico the concacaf
final so he's a champion he's christian
polisik who joins us on the program
have you come down after that win
against mexico
yeah um it's definitely a fun fun night
uh getting to celebrate with these guys
but yeah now we're relaxed one more game
to go so i'm trying to get focused
how do you prepare for atmosphere like
that
you really just you really don't i think
you just have to experience it i've i've
played in in concacaf matches before
i've played in some some very tough
places and uh
yeah the fans could be the fans can be
tough so there's really there's really
no getting ready for it it's just
getting those experiences
but did you worry though because you're
celebrating
and they're right there watching you
celebrate and
they're not happy i mean
it's just uh you know usa mexico
especially it's a big rivalry
and uh yeah we kind of know what's going
on but uh
it's uh it made it made the celebrations
and all that honestly that much better
is there a premier league rivalry that's
similar to u.s
mexico there's there's obviously big
rivalries i just don't think you can
compare it to uh
to the level of uh i guess just the
extent of
how the fans act and some of the things
that you see in the match
i just don't think i don't think you can
compare it in that way but there are
some big some big rivalries
and then you know you have your penalty
kick so can you put us in that moment of
do you think or try not to think
yeah definitely a mix of both um you
kind of you definitely have to try to
keep a cool head
you know in that moment especially with
a lot of a lot of fans booing and
it's it's it's tough so um i stepped up
there and just try to be confident and
yeah luckily i put it away but do you
look at the goalie
um not in that one i didn't honestly um
i kind of just said you know what i'm
going to pick a spot here
and i'm going to go for it and then
what's that feeling like though
when it leaves your foot
um when you take a penalty like that
especially and you put it real high it's
it's
you're a bit it's a bit nerve-wracking
until you you see it go in the net
so um it's uh it's it's a crazy feeling
but
yeah when once it goes in it's
definitely really there's so much hype
about you though christian
going into the premier league like do
you feel like you can ever live up to
everybody's expectations
oh you'll never live up to everyone's
expectations definitely something i've
learned
i just do the absolute best i can i'm
trying to prove
um but you know americans can do it you
know like especially across
europe and and doing it for the national
team now
so i just always give the best i can
because it's the game i love
and that's that's really all i can do
what was your second best sport growing
up
second best sport uh i would definitely
say
a golf golf or basketball um obviously i
didn't have the height
so i wasn't going to the nba but uh
you know i could shoot i had some
handles back in the day do you
still follow it yeah yeah um
on and off on and off i try to follow it
as best i can
uh the champions league when uh you know
you're going against man city
you know you come off the bench what are
you thinking when you uh
when you walk onto the pitch really just
doing whatever i can just to help impact
the game and help my team win in any way
that we can't you know in that moment it
was a lot of a lot of hard work a lot of
defending
you know we had to lead at that point so
yeah i really just said to myself go in
and try to
try to impact the game even if it's in
the smallest way and
that's really the mindset that i have
and then i saw the photo with you and
your parents
like that's a pretty good moment there
how do you describe that
extremely special they've they've
sacrificed so much
to help get me where i am so i'll always
be thankful for them and to share that
moment with
them uh obviously just very proud and uh
yeah it's definitely a day i'll never
forget you're covered for father's day
just so you know christian and mother's
day after you did that you don't have to
get
your parents a gift you don't have to
get him a card i don't think
i'll tell my mom that all right uh
the tattoos when did they start and did
mom have a problem with it
um that's uh
i i don't think my mom really did have
much of a problem with it i think my dad
already had some tattoos so
tattoos kind of were in the family
already so i was kind of uh
i definitely took it to a whole nother
level with the whole arm
sleep thing going but uh yeah my mom my
mom doesn't seem to
she doesn't love tattoos but she doesn't
she doesn't hate him on me either i
don't think
are you getting a celebratory tattoo
after you know
the champions league or beating mexico
uh i'm not sure about that um you know
get a
tattoo of the trophy here or something
like that oh i like that
i like that maybe i'll uh i'll have a
i'll have a chat with my artist
i was also wondering this you're a fan
of lebron's but he owns a piece of
liverpool
that's awkward isn't it christian i
guess that's awkward yeah uh we'll have
to have a
chat with him have you met have you met
lebron no i never had the chance to meet
him
no but i'll have to have a word with him
well why don't you invite him to a match
ah all right well
work on that yeah i think so um
how's your english accent you know
because sometimes you know celebrities
will live in
england and then all of a sudden they
come back with a little bit of an accent
or some phrases
so how are you doing with that my
english accent's all right i think
oh you can work on it a bit you know
give you a little things there but um no
i think i think uh i can do a good one i
haven't
quite uh i think i still sound american
i hope at least
well you're from the midwest but like
you don't you don't want to lose that
do you oh no um i i don't think so
well you're a man of mystery though if
you have an accent
because i remember madonna went there
uh who else uh gwyneth paltrow and then
they came back and they had
english accents we're like wait come on
yeah i lived i lived in there in the in
the uk actually when i was younger for
about a year and i was so young and i
was going to school there
i think by the end of the year some
people told me like they picked up on an
accent that i had already so
um i don't know i guess yeah you live
over there long enough it just starts
starts to be the usual for you um how
how concerned or uh how excited
confident are you with world cup
i think i think we're very i think we're
very confident i think we have a really
great group of guys i think i hope
you know a lot of americans could see
that um the other day
we have a confident bunch of guys guys
that are ready to fight and uh yeah
going to the region and
qualifying i think we're in a good place
but uh yeah we definitely want to we
want to be there we want to compete
i think you got a you know ethan horvath
you know how do you how do you give like
what do you give him after
he basically you know saved the uh saved
it
say he saved our country yeah yeah you
could say that yes
literally quite literally yeah um he uh
now i mean it couldn't happen to a
better guy to be honest um
the guy whether he's starting or not
he's the hardest worker he's constantly
ready
and uh to come into a game in an
atmosphere like that honestly just
really just shows what he's all about so
to come up in a big moment like that
it's just it's just massive
i just want to let you know that uh
cutter or qatar's is is going to be
really warm in 2022 so hydrate prepare
yourself there christian
okay that's good advice have you have
you played in that kind of heat before
i don't know about that kind of heat um
i've definitely
yeah i've lived in florida and played
down there which is warm but i don't
think you can compare so we'll see
what's the worst weather you ever played
in
the worst weather that's tough to say i
think we had a really tough
uh snow game this year uh which was
brutal
um snow and soccer community
well they don't let you dress
appropriately for that right
no exactly you still gotta you're still
in your shorts and you're
in your jersey so uh well
congratulations great moment for you
uh a couple of great moments for you and
uh certainly with
your parents there along for the ride we
appreciate your time and uh thanks for
joining us
yeah thank you so much christian palisic
captain america